als ich bin gerade am aufräumen und habe
gemerkt dass der parkettboden komplett
zerkratzt ist weil ich ihren stuhl hat
er einfach keine films leider hatte
grund ist der pakt wurden hier kaputt
guckt euch das mal
komplett viele kratzer das ist echt
total blöd und jetzt habe ich den
ultimativen tipp für euch vor meiner
freundin ihr nehmt der wahllos und jetzt
guckt euch das fand ich echt wie
zauberei wie magie
bleibt die wahl muss darüber
einfach drüber schreiben über das
kaputte holz
und jetzt
der kratzer ist weg erstaunlich normal
einfach drüber schreiben nicht essen
sondern darüber reiben
der wahnsinn